[Music]
in staying alive news I would think of
that office episode every time when
they're learning submitted by Ryan a
woman who fell off a cruise ship was
rescued after treading water for 10
hours oh thank god cuz usually when that
happens they just get lost
yeah rescue you know ten hours that's
amazing did she play water I'm done in
ten minutes
that's I'm done ten seconds training
otters do not tread water my body's not
like designed for treading water at all
I can't do it let's try this
I still can't try to walk you go in the
pool and then do this thing
like an angel you float yeah that takes
very little energy to do yeah I just
gotta hold your breath not even you got
to hold it you just gotta breathe and
you float so if you hold your breath you
go your point signals you know how to
keep your lungs oh yeah you exhale
through your mouth and inhale through
your nose you just keep your lungs open
you just yeah if you want to draw at the
bottom you exhale all your air
you just you breathe no I'm saying if
you hold your breath in you'll you'll be
more buoyant so you keep her under the
water and then you hold your breath a
minute well that's all folks she's 46
years old her name is okay oh that's
okay huh she was on a cruise ship and
the Adriatic Sea switch the left Croatia
heading towards Venice and that's what
she fell off the back she must have been
doing I always assume everyone's just
doing the Titanic that's exactly what I
was imagining sure that's the only way I
can picture you falling off it you're
under that front of the boat the lady
just throwing jewelry out like
[ __ ] mark just was like if I
fall off the back I'm not gonna get
annihilated by this cruise ship that
selfish ass [ __ ] she fell off the boat
cuz there's CCTV footage of her falling
off I'm sorry I pictured it and they
what's funny in my head is funny I don't
know why pictures are doing a cartwheel
and then falling off I think kind of
falling off like this just
staring for like five seconds before she
does a moment I knew it
so Sheila she fell at 11:30 p.m. on
Saturday on the dark that scary black
out there she didn't get rescued until
9:45 a.m. the next day it's cool they
don't got sharks there how does it even
know dude okay biotic see it's like a
big-ass lake no it's like a ocean still
big but it's huge yeah it's just it's
mainly the Russian mafia okay and there
were likely to see smuggling nukes and
stuff how did they know though CCTV
footage well I'm pretty sure she didn't
travel by herself
maybe someone reported it is a good
question because they don't mention that
probably like oh we can't find her
though let's get the CCTV there she is
right there there she goes another one
doing that Titanic pose you gotta stop
burning shoes
you're the painless movie people for
love from back then the communities off
cuz it's from Asia well she fell by
herself but White's question is pretty
valid cuz they don't mention like how
they figured it out I just wanted to see
what happened like maybe like somebody
like accidentally pushed her off and
then she falls off in the guy's life you
see a walk off maybe that happened who
knows I think they would have mentioned
if she was pushed off yeah cuz it was
recorded this is amazing that she
survived through the midnight for ten
hours she didn't get hypothermia or
frostbite or anything like that because
the water was around 75 degrees
o come summer beautiful comfy and she
was saying that 75 degrees water that's
conflict they were saying that she's in
good shape and like hobo the rescuers
she was able to survive because she's
into yoga and she was able to like float
in the sea and just she was also singing
so she doesn't fall asleep that's
amazing yes I've ever shared a tap into
she did it oh that's true cuz when the
water is warm I bet it's like so easy to
sleep I can't believe she survived that
embarrassment that's so crazy to me that
you so [ __ ] embarrassed oh it's just
hi were they trying to save me dude
so he's like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
she's all like the [ __ ] doing this
now like no just yeah but can I come in
real quick guys breather
yeah give me clothes in future the
cruise ship doing a u-turn coming back
in everybody's like looking outside and
yeah dude I feel like a lot of people
would be pissed because she did delay
the yeah but this is okay she's a UK
resident okay okay oh yeah she was just
saying how hey she's really in shape she
looks elderly she looks like she's good
with water yeah she does come off very
like that like yeah this is a photo but
she was being rescued
that is wild dude that is wild I would
be so defeated be like but how I died
hours I would've died let's do a
ten-hour swim challenge you go first
all right my dinner you'll be really
jumping you're near sea and swim for 10
hours with nobody from miles around
don't forget to like this video before
you I hope she drank a lot of water
before she jumped down the area on the
cruise that's really healthy and they
blocked it off that's where she fell I
would have been dehydrated why would
they block that off cuz they're like oh
this area like it's easy for you to fall
out of I don't know I was thinking about
the crime scene at the crime scene you
got to get all the evidence somebody
pushed her off oh yeah she's so lucky
she survived she has a lottery I think I
read something that about like 17% like
there have been about 300 people since
the year 2000 that have fallen off and
about 17% get rescued
well people actually get rescued I
thought all of them would die like
that's it cuz when we were Nara crews I
would look down and be like yup that's
death especially in the waters of Mexico
gone that thought wasn't near as big as
our cruise ship our coach I was like
falling down like two stories like it's
yeah building splat into water if you're
the Norwegian maybe even like 10 stories
yeah
if I fall come out the street strip ship
I hope I break my [ __ ] neck and died
on impact because I'm just hate to like
slowly die like this
I agree you know I hope I die like
something there's a stray bullet for
some reason but you guys would be ok
with trying to survive in a zombie
apocalypse cuz that's what I would want
to kill myself oh yeah you're not
constantly trying to survive in a zombie
by swimming what you started wrong it's
all swimming like cool right the minute
you lose that second of time you're
drowning you're dead yeah zombie you can
at least oh here's a tree hide like
there's no like there's no such thing as
a break in swimming and we don't know
the zombies if they're gonna be the
fastest or they're gonna be the ones
that drive their foot cuz if they're
dragging their foot it'll be fun
I'll just wait for them to come to me
they're in big The Walking Dead kind of
zombie check it out though it's only
gonna last like three days but there's
so season while you did we're just like
chilling and then all this on the turn
around there's a zombie like you didn't
hear it watch them all just shuffle his
feet for like try The Walking Dead was
so weird like when they get would get
surprised tacked by something so slow
walking dead they're just like it's like
a sloth [ __ ] you up yeah I think I
would much rather be yeah and it's only
like three days cuz all the maggots and
all the [ __ ] weather and it's kind of
[ __ ] up all the zombies anyway you just
kind of hold out for somewhere it's not
gonna be three days it is zombies have
to decompose yeah and they can't it's
gonna be three days the one I'm really
afraid about of is the whole robots that
everyone's creating now that's the one
that I'm like that can actually happen
then we're fine will you be a robot
slave it's no good you know how some
people they just wants to you'll arity
of happening cuz they like just get it
over with
I want to be on the robot side
what do they imagine that they would be
as they want to be remembered as like
the one that helped the robots out also
the robots like a bunch of punk-ass
[ __ ] yeah okay Arnold ass mark ass
[ __ ] well I ain't helping
nobody but my own kind so it's kind of
like those people that think that Isis
is like super nice or like that this
couple they biked through isolation and
they got killed immediately to prove
that they're not yeah that there's other
they just hit him with a truck what yeah
it's like this [ __ ] stupid-ass
hipster couple that they wanted to prove
like it's safe out there's just like war
propaganda and they're like Isis is cool
so then they win a [ __ ] bike Road and
like I don't know just kill them yeah
and a but they just got on a truck and
just smash them and [ __ ] all Muslims are
agree we're all human yeah but every
community has really shitty crazy people
absolutely if I go to like KKK territory
and I'm like you know want singularity
to happen they just imagine like oh yeah
we'll be fine really not they know we're
gonna [ __ ] die but they just want to
be on the like hopefully it's like the
robots will be on there too yeah
look there I'm gonna be dead by then I
don't give a [ __ ] my kids got to deal
with that [ __ ] [ __ ] them so sad you
[ __ ] coward what did I say like I'm
gonna bring a kid into this world good
luck Bodhi yeah my kids will I don't
know [ __ ] them okay I don't know I think
there's always gonna be a way to
override it like a hacker will always be
able to all right well yes no I like oh
I thought robots I was like nah not
really
I think they're just gonna like evolved
humans but they've we've been getting
groomed dude think about it like weird
so dependent on technology now that
we're slowly getting groomed so think
about but that's humans grooming us with
robots consumerism like would like the
same people that invented apps or the
same
the machines the same psychologist thank
you it's the same people that have made
I'm a robot I'm sorry yeah
robots that's a selfish reason robots a
psychic I think robots or like
technology will just evolved humans into
the next but I wonder the control we
bought it you guys gonna come over and
watch it it's really good robots they
don't understand irrational thinking and
they don't understand love so we're
gonna heart them to death think of like
emulator but they still don't understand
consciousness they won't it's not like
her
[Music]